You know, Democrats and the Republicans are the category.
The Republicans and Democrats differ.
Like on the rare occasions when I vote, and they're pretty rare,...
...sometimes I vote for Democrats, sometimes for Republicans, sometimes for somebody else.
It's not a sharp split. They're two factions of the same party.
We have a one-party state with two somewhat different factions with a lot of overlap.
Business Party has a couple of factions.
By a little bit, you'd find some differences between them.
I wouldn't say there's no difference on the average.
So, what should you do in that case?
Well, like everything, it's your own choice.
Do you wanna live in a democratic society or do you wanna live in the society we have?
Which, remember, is not a democratic society and it's not intended to be.
If you take the course in political theory here,...
...I'm sure they'll teach you that the United States is not a democracy.
It's what's called in the technical literature, a polyarchy.
That's the term invented by the leading democratic theorist at Yale, Professor Robert Dahl.
But the idea is old,...
...very, just way back to James Madison and the foundation of the Constitution.
A polyarchy is a system in which power resides in the hands of those who Madison called...
...the wealth of the nation,...
...the responsible class of men,...
...and the rest of the population is fragmented, distracted,...
...and allowed to participate every couple of years.
They're allowed to come and say, "Yes, thank you."
"Why don't you continue for another four years?"
And they have a little choice among the responsible men or the wealth of the nation.